Tom yes you auditioned for Ken I did
many times but Pacific where I'm talking
about Thor Loki would you had to changed
your life it did yeah my life has
changed thanks to this man yes and it's
a pleasure to be sitting with him on
your sofa is that where the Hiddleston's
came from from Loki III that's a whole
other world I don't know about you know
all about the hidden stone yeah they're
very sweet mostly benign yeah there's a
few of them and then the Idul stoners
get little boners from here not me I
don't know I did I've never that's
something I've not even put up and put
that out into your pardon the expression
I haven't extended that into thee no
it's a there generally you know they're
fit generally I farmers have lost for
words okay Gobert okay like they've
sweet and benign and they and their fans
and and and yeah you're fabulous as Loki
Thank You lien buggers apparently you
originally originally or dish no offense
is meant by my incredulity here that's
right but you originally auditioned for
Thor yeah did you encourage him to do
that Kim uh it was a it was a very sort
of brilliant kind of pitch for the part
I mean he'd come in and wowed the room
but with for as Loki and a store we were
it we were an emerging and evolving
scripts that was always changing but
fair play to Tom he just went for it in
the end of Ken why did you go with this
then longer hair
I think it was the hair that's my
brother from another mother
for both or chris hemsworth is made out
of genetically modified material he
wouldn't mind my saying that he's a sort
of genetic anomaly I think I was very I
was a bit embarrassed when when we came
to do the scene in the movie where he
takes his shirt off I just felt a little
uncomfortable talking about the sort of
how we would do it and I felt as though
well maybe he'll feel that he shouldn't
or could nor it's a bit whatever sy said
I remember going to see him that morning
saying look you know I would it would be
I think it might be good if you get your
shirt off but on you may be fitting he
said oh I gotta get my bloody shirt off
my hobby
I'm trying if on knowing much about
what if you do got me boxed in so
welcome so for you but on the show